I wouldn't have thought this is my dream
role but now honestly like I can't stop
thinking about it um I talked to Todd a
lot about what else we might be able to
do in general just working together but
also specifically is there something
else with Joker that that might be
interesting so it ended up being a dream
rule I don't it's it's nothing that that
I really wanted to do prior to to work
are you saying that yes you don't do
sequels you know there's no to even say
that there's more to do I don't know
that there is there is but you're not
closed-minded about it no and it's you
know I think me Todd would still be
shooting now if we could write because
it seemed endless the possibilities of
where we could go with the character you
don't have any dream to be in a scene
with Batman no Ivan had that I've had
that dream we'll see could be coming
because the Batman is coming so who
knows right it's just up there
welcome back everyone is Charlie we have
to talk about Joker - it sounds like
Joaquin Phoenix actually wants to do a
sequel to The Joker movies so we'll
break it down there's a lot of things
that they've said about it since the
movie has come out we're doing a new
round of the movie ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
about the Joker sequel on the video so
if you're not sure what's going on here
he's just been doing a lot of interviews
in and around the movie saying about how
much he loved the process how hypnotized
he was by the character and even though
he acknowledges in the past he's not a
person that does a lot of sequels he
feels like there's so many directions
that they can take this Arthur Joker
character in the future so here's my top
10 predictions for what that would be
based on the way they've talked about
this and the way Warner Brothers to sort
of bubble this type of film off in its
DC Black Label film universe outside of
the normal Justice League films very big
spoiler warning for the Joker movie if
you haven't seen it yet because we need
to talk about very specific plot points
and the end of that movie starting with
number 10 you start with a story of The
Joker breaking out of Arkham Asylum
where they leave things at the end of
the first Joker film I know the way they
edited that scene makes you wonder
whether or not it's really happening but
I do think it's meant to represent that
he's slowly breaking out of Arkham and
he killed that person that was
interviewing him inside the cell so you
begin with that there's a short time
jump for a couple of years in the next
movie the situation in Gotham only
deteriorates Q more jokes about giant
rats in the sewers
they can then introduce a very young
version of Detective Gordon as a young
rookie who hasn't made detective yet who
starts to unravel the mystery behind the
Joker after his display on live
television during the Murray Franklin TV
show so you have to imagine that what he
did on the Murray Franklin TV show was
watched by so many people so many
potential future Batman villains but
also other characters like detective
Gordon 9 because he's been in Arkham
Asylum and because they're setting these
movies in the past early to mid 80s
period for the sequel
you can also introduce another version
of dr. Harleen Quinzel before she
becomes Harley Quinn and is turned by
the Joker but it's not the Margot Robbie
Harley Quinn Arkham Asylum is just this
untapped resource for Batman movies
right now with so much story potential
and so many Batman characters flowing
from that play
so eight you begin and in the sequel
movie at Arkham Asylum but while you're
at our commune traduce a few more
Batman's rogues gallery of villains as
they slowly start to get their origin
stories - the same way they did the
origin story of the Joker in the first
movie Hugo Strange as another really saw
it pick he can be another doctor at
Arkham and because the Joker movie twist
is that it shows Arthur as this tragic
villain of circumstance and Thomas Wayne
is a person who comes off more as an
antagonist you can treat Hugo Strange
the same way you treated Thomas Wayne
during the Joker movie someone who
abuses patients at Arkham experiments on
them someone who you would normally put
all of your trust in like you trust
Thomas Wayne to fix the city but because
Hugo Strange is a pretty notable Batman
villain of course he would be doing
terrible things to the patients in
Arkham 7 you also treat some of the
sequels at Arkham Asylum as Grant
Morrison's Arkham Asylum story without
Batman because that is technically a
Batman story is this crazy fever dream
of the Joker playing with the idea of
what's real and what's false you do it
as a really trippy nightmare and you can
continue with the idea that Arthur's off
of his meds and you can never really be
sure if what's happening is actually
happening or if he's just imagining it
six Joker can also inspire other classic
Batman villains through his act on the
Murray Franklin TV show like the penguin
Mad Hatter scarecrow the Riddler and you
can do the sequel as an origin story of
sorts for at least one of them but
because it's a smaller film you would
pick one and just zero in on them like a
scarecrow origin story or a Riddler
origin story but because it would be
part of this DC black label universe of
films it would be rated R so it would be
less of a Jim Carrey version of the
Riddler
Riddler is just a character in the
comics who has had a lot of bad history
with the Joker so even though it's x it
seems like Batman villains team-up the
Joker definitely hates the Riddler
scarecrow is also another solid pick for
a young scientist who could be working
out of Arkham Asylum under Hugo Strange
in five with the way the Joker movie is
commentary on the way we as society deal
with mental health issues and people who
are mentally ill you can also portray
the other classic Batman villains in
that same way more as tragic villains
who don't necessarily start out bad but
are pushed to violence through their
circumstances around them in the
system's of Gotham the local government
the police the rich like the Wayne
family
fail them completely the same way they
failed Arthur as he was slowly becoming
the Joker so that by the end they had
nothing left to lose just like Arthur
said to Murray Franklin I have nothing
left to lose and you don't have to
necessarily turn them into heroes
because the Joker isn't a hero in this
movie but you are able to understand why
he does the terrible things he does
without necessarily condoning his
actions or because they sound like
they're not going straight to a version
of Batman you still bring back a
slightly older but very young version of
Bruce Wayne as a side character he's not
the main story while you're doing these
other Batman bill and origin stories
like the Riddler and you just show Bruce
Wayne
slowly suffering from some of the same
and mental and social problems as the
Batman villains suffer from like his
mental health deteriorates in the same
way the villains mental health starts
deteriorating making it a little more
believable that one day he will think
that it's a good idea to dress up like a
bat and run around Gotham by night
taking down criminals that's the whole
concept of Joker's speech to Batman
during Killing Joke everyone else is
just like me all it takes is one bad day
three give Joker a worthy opponent and
someone like the Riddler or even the
court of owls another villain or group
of villains who feel like they have a
claim to Gotham and want to impose their
order in control of the city whereas the
Joker wouldn't have any of that he would
hate the court of owls just as much as
he hates Batman because not only are
they the rich elite that treat people
like garbage they're also just as much
to blame for the bad state of Gotham
City as people like Thomas Wayne like
the rich people saying that will fix
everything but then do nothing to help
the people that really need it to
eventually you do have a bigger time
jump but instead of doing the normal
version of Batman you see in the pg-13
family-friendly Batman movies you turn
this version of Bruce Wayne in something
closer to a hardcore flashpoint Batman
only it's Bruce Wayne instead of Thomas
Wayne Batman much more in the tone of
something that matches the intensity
from what you see in this Joker movie
but you do it as a much smaller more
intimate film in number one because it
would be smaller less Batman gadgetry
you do a third film as a Killing Joke
style film the
to do the animated version of that film
rated-r because the subject matter is so
hardcore it would be perfect for a DC
Black Label film you had people talk
about how Ben Affleck was so hardcore
and serious in Batman V Superman the
tone of his Batman during those movies
is much more in keeping with a tone of
these DC black label films so you lean
into that but you do it as a smaller
noir detective story where if Warner
Brothers takes a hard pass on doing any
kind of version of Batman in these DC
black label films you still jump forward
in time and you just make Hugo Strange
or the Riddler his biggest villain and
do it as a war of jokes and riddles
movie there been so many times in the
comics that Batman's villains have gone
to war with each other instead of going
to war with Batman
so that would totally work inside a
Joker sequel but let me know in the
comments if they do make a Joker sequel
what do you want that movie to be and if
there are any more rumblings about it I
will do more Joker sequel videos will be
ramping up to start production on the
Batman movies pretty soon too so I will
do more Batman movies as we get more
details
congradulations average Titan you're the
giveaway winner for my last big DC video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details I've
already done a bunch of Easter egg
videos about the Joker movie click here
for my Joker ending scene and easter
eggs video playlists and click here to
watch them talk about what's going on
with the Batman movie plot thank you so
much for watching
everybody put on a happy face I'll see
you guys tonight